Oh
I suppose my interest in looking for
life elsewhere in the universe really
dates back to my teens what teenager
doesn't look up at the sky at night and
think am I alone in the universe well
most people get over it but I never did
and though I made a career more in
physics and cosmology than astrobiology
I've always had a soft spot for the
subject of life because it does seem so
mysterious to physicists life looks
nothing short of a miracle it's just
amazing what living things can do and so
that sense of mystery that sense of how
did it all begin it has always been
there in the background and then in the
1990s I began to take a more active part
began to study the prospects that life
could spread from Mars to earth or maybe
Earth to Mars and that maybe life began
on Mars and came to earth and that idea
seemed to have a lot of traction and is
now accepted as very plausible and so I
was asked to help create the Australian
Centre for astrobiology a living a bad
time in Australia and we set this thing
up in Sydney and I worked there for some
years before moving to Arizona
when I first suggested the idea in the
early 1990s that life could have come
from Mars to earth inside rocks blasted
off the red planet by Comet and asteroid
impacts think a lot of people felt that
this was a pretty crackpot notion but it
became clear during the 1990s they're
not only that there is a large traffic
of material exchange between Mars and
Earth but the microbes are hardy enough
if protected by the rock cocooned inside
to survive the harsh conditions of outer
space for a long time many millions of
years and the evidence both theoretical
and experimental has firmed up and I
think many people now realize that if
you get life on either Mars or F you'll
get it on both planets from this
splashing phenomenon now the case for a
beginning on Mars is not very strong
mouse is a smaller planet so it cooled
quicker so it was ready for life sooner
conditions there were more congenial for
life to get going but as we don't know
how life ever got going this is a bit of
a leap in the dark so we certainly can't
say that it definitely started on Mars
but it seems very plausible that he did
a math seems as good a place as Earth
for life to get started
I think astrobiologists are comfortable
with the idea that could have started on
Mars and come here the as I've said the
evidence is not compelling but to really
clinch this we would of course need to
either go to Mars and find life there
and discover it's the same life as we
have here on earth or just possibly a
sample return mission which has been
long awaited by the astrobiology
community this is a spacecraft that
would be sent to Mars and pick up a sort
of grab bag of rocks and bring them back
to earth so they could be studied it's
just possible we will find traces of
life in those rocks it's equally
possible we won't so it's a bit of a
long shot the only way to be really
clear is to have some expedition to Mars
and my feeling is that life on Mars
today is almost certainly is there at
all deep under the ground maybe a
kilometer or so beneath the surface and
so that's going to be hard to get